[Music]
here in this video we will showcase 10
of the most iconic and most powerful
interdimensional monsters seen in movies
and shows so without any further ado
please subscribe and if you already have
then let's get on with this monster
content
number 10 the project arrowhead
creatures from the movie the miss
they are monstrous inhabitants of an
alternate reality they are the result of
a top-secret government experiment that
involves many scientists called the
arrowhead project intended to peer into
another dimension but this went terribly
wrong and the other reality was merged
with the earth
deadly creatures like the tentacles from
planet x the arachno lobster and the
behemoth managed to enter the u.s the
united states through various bottles
and along with the foggy atmosphere they
started to cause havoc to the entire
world
number nine the event horizon ship from
the movie the event horizon
the ship event horizon is a space-faring
experimental vessel that was possessed
by an evil force it was capable of
faster than light travel using an
artificial black hole to open a portal
from one part of the universe to another
on its maiden voyage the ship was
thought to be lost but in reality it
used its faster than light engine to
travel beyond the boundaries of our
dimension into another one
one of pure chaos and evil and came back
possessed by the malevolence of that
dimension and having supernatural powers
number eight the wall of monsters from
the movie in the mouth of madness
these are a group of evil beings from
another dimension that want to enter the
earthly plane to conquer the planet and
eradicate all humans this group of
grotesque looking monsters found a way
to the current reality by way of belief
and how they did that was very cunning
they gave their stories to an author a
horror story author and in the end of
the movie they succeed to break through
the doorway beneath a creepy church and
begin their evil plans
their powers include madness and
corruption influence some godly powers
and reality warping
number 7 abelisk from the guardians of
the galaxy vol 2.
the obelisk was a giant tentacle monster
that was also multi-dimensional in
origin it was the one that was seen in
the opening scenes battling the
guardians it had multiple tentacles and
a pinkish skin that is very super
durable i able to withstand any type of
projectiles and energy based weapons
fired at it this creature was able to
spew out a rainbow called quantum breath
from its mouth it was near
indestructible except for one opening
below its neck it also had the ability
to traverse two different dimensions one
that was kind of similar to america
travis from the movie doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness
number six mind flayer from the series
called stranger things
also known as the shadow monster or more
commonly just him
he is the antagonist of the second and
third seasons of that show the mind
flayer is a gargantuan entity being at
least 50 stories tall his body appears
to be entirely composed of minuscule
particles giving him a misty appearance
akin to that of a shadow
this creature has multiple limbs some of
which branch into smaller several
smaller appendages
it is the nexus of a hive mind it can
possess humans can alter the weather has
biotechnological and biology
manipulation powers as well
number five the dweller in darkness from
shangti and the legend of the ten rings
this was the leader of the soul eaters
creatures with the ability to absorb and
feed on souls it is a kaiju size
creature with elements of a dragon and a
cephalopod in its appearance it is an
ancient extra-dimensional entity that
attacked and nearly destroyed a
pocket-dimensional world called the
tallow it completely wrecked the
advanced civilization in that realm but
was later trapped by the combined powers
of the people of tallow
along with a mystical dragon called the
great protector
number four the antiverse kaiju from the
movies of the pacific rim universe
these kaiju are creations of another
advanced interdimensional race of beings
called the precursors
both they and their creators hail from
another dimension called the antiverse
and their main goal is to colonize earth
kaijus are creatures of a highly toxic
nature gigantic in size and highly
aggressive with the only weapons capable
of defeating them are the jaegers and
nuclear weapons kaiju can survive in any
type of environments and enter the
planet via gateways called breaches
number three void ghidorah from the
anime movie godzilla the planet eater
this incarnation of king ghidorah is an
extraterrestrial energy being from
another dimension which evolved to
discard its physical form in favor of a
purely energy based form
while ghidorah retains the classic image
of a three-headed dragon with two wings
two tails and two legs he doesn't really
stand upright and is positioned
horizontally rather than vertically
this ghidorah is also partially
transparent and is fiery in form
the body is seen in the shape of
immensely long electric necks which were
able to wrap around godzilla and suck
the energy out of him
number 2 the leviathan from the
hellraiser franchise
he is the creator of the powerful
demonic entities known as the cenobytes
which included pinhead he is also known
as the god of flesh hunger and desire
and resides inside an extra dimensional
world known as the labyrinth he appears
as a strange ominous form of a massive
long narrow octahedron in the center of
that cenobite realm the leviathan's
origin is unknown but some believe that
he is a fallen angel and despises humans
for their lack of law and order with the
human being viewed as chaotic and wrong
by him he is one powerful metal dude
and number one dormammu from the movie
doctor strange
he is a primordial interdimensional
entity who wields apocalyptic levels of
supernatural power and rules the dark
dimension dormammu seeks to conquer
every universe of the multiverse as well
as that of earth he is nothing more or
less than the ultimate personification
of destruction megalomania and
ruthlessness he appears to be the being
of pure and utter malevolence he is
gigantic in size up to thousands of feet
in height and maybe even more and has
absolute control of his own realm which
would make him a god of his own
dimension
and that is the most powerful and iconic
interdimensional monster in this list
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam